how do you know when someone is
interested in you I'm in my early 30s
and still no expert and kind of
embarrassed to admit this but absolutely
oblivious at times when to others it's
been obvious your gauge of whether
someone likes you can all it doesn't
have to be all or nothing like I'm going
to assume they like me and then I'm
going to walk up to them and ask them
out it doesn't have to be quite that
direct you can give a little bit and see
what happens like tease them a little
bit see if they tease you back talk
about a coffee place that you like and
want to go to and that you have half an
hour you might go there now and see if
they want to come with you you don't
have to immediately act as if I have to
have all the information right now to
know if they like me